yeah there is a video uh with the trans
activist that staged the walk out for
the dave chappelle netflix special
and there were a bunch of old tweets
that she had tweeted out
yeah that resurfaced it was a lot of
racist [ __ ] against uh asians gays and
uh hispanics how interesting
that this is
and what she said was way worse than me
so
don't talk to that person because
they're they're not um a good person no
activist behind netflix has made several
it's so bad thank you now where was the
outcry for this where's where's
the picketing for netflix no there's no
outright she worked that next door
people aren't gonna stop no she was the
main like oh like
yeah yeah calling on the pro team [ __ ]
her look at these
bro i'd beat them
it's always the people who walk outside
this stuff come out against them
i'm like aw
so she's talking about a gay man here
asian hoes act like they won't get
karate chopped in their throat what's
the whole staring at my business [ __ ]
latino and asian businesses need to stop
being rude and [ __ ] disrespectful i
know it's a lot to ask california but
speak english
this is a great person another damn
agent almost hit me while crossing what
the f is with y'all in the damn vehicles
i have an idea yeah
yep this asian ninja in subway got fat
ass he almost looks like a [ __ ] from
behind now this is way worse than
anything they should have said you think
this person is an [ __ ] yeah get the
[ __ ] out of here i love it this is
exactly what it is look at this just
that asian [ __ ] clean the [ __ ] out you
messed up my order then blame me hashtag
english is my first language [ __ ] never
ordered yeah what the [ __ ] so and then
and now she's the one yeah going after
dave chabelle what a surprise
what is the [ __ ] awesome this helps
this this helps the movement as far as
the backlash the backlash we are in the
middle of a good backlash it's like
[ __ ] the rest of us don't have to
deal with this [ __ ]
they're not anytime i read about this
i'm like you're not trying to make the
world the tweet
appear to have been deleted since yeah
no [ __ ] you're interested in power and
destruction yeah oh look at that
although those tweets were referred to
refer
surfaced as a political play i take full
responsibility for my actions deeply
applies those i finna hurt sure i
apologize uh at over seven half years
clean and sober i've learned to make
amends when i'm wrong take complete
accounting i didn't have education and
mentorship
that i have now also not struggling on
drugs that oh oh so you're on drugs
yeah what makes me mad about that is
that like that doesn't get that doesn't
give you the right to like go after
people like you've done wrong too yeah
you know what i mean so it's like and
like and now you want the comment yeah
special taken down because of a few
jokes she just doesn't know yeah
[ __ ] that person